let's get it out of the way friday night
friday morning mom let's back this
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah he called
again and then he double checked again
this ain't even my kid and then he
called again be on alert i dropped a
thousand milligrams of abx freezing my
balls off it's like when i was a kid and
i go to the bronx and these [ __ ]
people will let spirits go into them and
then they'd wake up like what happened
you follow me that's me
this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [ __ ] it's
monday the 4th of april let's start the
month off on the right foot listen
tonight is the national championship the
ncaa's
from the heart of new jersey the joint
is brought to you by draftkings
tonight's tonight guys
it's carroll north carolina versus
[ __ ] kansas i don't know what
the line is but let me tell you
something if you were gonna sign up for
draftkings today is the [ __ ]
day because i got a tremendous week for
you to get in on the action tonight you
can buy the same gay parlay make a
little dough and if you bet five dollars
on whatever college team you're gonna
get 200 and free credits and that's when
this weekend comes up when there's two
titles up for grab on the stacked ufc
273 card you got bolonoski against the
[ __ ] korean zombie join the
action with draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc plus you got cosmo chemist against
gilbert burns you got new jersey's
mickey [ __ ] gal and you got another
fight al jermain sterling versus peter
yan it's time to make some cash everyone
can play
do me a favor now if there's no sports
book in your [ __ ] state
do me a favor you could also get in on
millions and dollars of prizes with
draftkings daily fantasy mma contest
draft your lineup of fighters while
staying under the salary cap and rack up
points for strikes takedowns and more
draftkings are safe secure and reliable
and best of all you can deposit and
withdraw cash whenever you want download
the draftking sportsbook app right now
use promo code joey throw down five
bucks tonight
on kansas or north carolina you win uh
203 bets for this weekend's ufc 273
that's code joey for this saturday's
draftking sports book the official
sports betting part of the ufc must be
21 and restrictions
do apply the joint is also brought to
you by the best cbd lion listen
i've been with them for four years and i
fall in love with them more more every
week
those delta nine gummies are on [ __ ]
fire
nice legit delivered right to your house
nobody knows nothing and i'm gonna give
you 20 off when you go to cbd lion
press code joey or joint and get 20 off
that's a great deal on those delta nines
you're not gonna get that again so go to
cbd lion read about the third party lab
results and try the delta nines or the
cbd gummies with melatonin and now
without further ado
it's time to get this [ __ ]
party started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's a beautiful monday morning
april the [ __ ] fought the first
quarter is done if you [ __ ] didn't
wake up from your [ __ ] slumber it's
time to wake up [ __ ] because it's
getting real out there
anyway it was a great [ __ ] week uh
last week
you know with the lead thing this
weekend
was [ __ ] phenomenal in more ways than
one but i didn't do anything you ever
have those weekends where you're like
[ __ ]
i'm tired but i didn't do [ __ ] but let's
get it out of the way friday night
friday morning
no let's back this [ __ ] up about
two weeks ago i got a call from tom
siguri you guys know
he's my [ __ ] brother i love
that dude and uh
he told me he wanted to come back here
and he was coming back here for a week
and he wanted to see me one of the
nights i should come to one of the shows
and i was like yeah yeah yeah
you know the last thing i want to do is
go to a [ __ ] comedy show but uh
he called again
and then he double checked again and i
had already plans for friday night i
mean there weren't i was gonna go to the
field watch the kids and then go to
dinner with the parents
i got to the field it was [ __ ]
freezing out that [ __ ] i mean
that and i'm like this ain't even my kid
that's playing why am i out here [ __ ]
freezing my balls off
and then he called again and he's like
bro you coming the show starts at 7 30.
i don't like driving at night
so i had called a friend of mine he
hadn't called me back yet
uh to maybe take a ride up there so i
said listen let me uh i called my coach
over at uh hollis grace my man shawn
and i said listen be on alert we might
go to tom segura
and he's like i'm in and i was like i
don't know if i want to go
and at the field tom hit me again and he
goes listen you come and i go listen i
can't get a ride he goes listen i'll
send an uber once he said you send an
uber i'm like [ __ ] it
i'll go i call my man sean i call
florentine once they say they're going
to send listen everybody invite you to
things right in this life people like
i'd love for you to come and you're like
i don't want to go nowhere
but once they say listen i'm sending a
call for you okay then if if you want me
there that much
i see you i'll [ __ ] be there
so i met sean i met jimmy florentine and
we took a ride up to [ __ ] newark
newark looked beautiful that night i
mean on the way out then i saw the bums
and the crackholes and you know people
trying to mug people but newark on a
friday night is beautiful especially
with tom was
we got down there and to boot not only
did he say [ __ ]
i'll send an uber he goes if you drive
i'll give you backstage parking right
behind the [ __ ] bus you don't have to
walk or anything i mean listen he made
it
as easy as can be for uncle joey you
follow me
we get up there
now i forgot to drop the [ __ ] main
thing but before i went to the football
field i dropped a thousand milligrams of
abx
because i didn't you know it's not my
kid and [ __ ] we're going to dinner so i
want to spruce up the [ __ ] uh the
appetite a little bit just go out and
giggle with the parents you know they
don't get high so the side of the table
i sit with they don't get eyes so
i just [ __ ] goof around with them and
[ __ ]
so i had already a thousand i had five
of those abx
uh
cbo [ __ ] capsules i gave lee one on a
friday he called me tuesday he said he
just came down from it those things are
strong i inhaled five of those
[ __ ]
in the car on the way there it was
starting to hit me like i was giggling
in my head by myself and [ __ ]
and i'm like i'm gonna go
sit enjoy [ __ ] time watch a little
stand-up comedy you know
we get there we can't get in the back
[ __ ] gate they won't hear us finally
i call tom i don't like about listen
when you're a comedian and you invite
somebody to your show the last thing i
want is a text message or a call
10 minutes before my show to tell me you
can't find parking or some other stupid
[ __ ] figure it the [ __ ] out i gave you
free [ __ ] tickets what else do you
want me to do for you figure it out but
10 minutes before a show i don't want to
know about your cat
i don't want to know about your mother i
don't want to know about nothing
i'm going to a place and i'll see you
afterward i'm going to a place it's like
when i was a kid and i go to the bronx
and these [ __ ] people will let
spirits go into them and then they'd
wake up like what happened that's me
listen i 10 minutes before my game time
i don't want to hear about your parking
i don't want to hear that you can't you
don't can't figure out where to go
figure it the [ __ ] out get back in your
car and leave
but don't the people you invite to your
shows this is why when a ufc fighter
fights in his hometown you bet against
him
because yeah he's going back there to
[ __ ] win but not really he's got 20
people that want free tickets where do
we sit can i meet dana white
can i come to the great yeah and you're
like no
so anyway to make a long story short i
just figured it out by 7 30 i go you
know we got to do something
so i texted road managers road manager
hit me back pressed the button it was
just a buzzer we had to press that was
it
we went in there and tom waited for me
outside
so as i greeted him and gave him a hug
he goes we're running late
do you want to bring me up now guys i
didn't even think about it
at that point the edible was doing all
the [ __ ] thinking right i didn't even
think about it i go yeah why not
and we started walking in and i didn't
even realize what i had said to him and
he's like we're walking to the stage
right now
and you know i don't know how many
people would have five thousand three
thousand eight thousand i have no
[ __ ] idea
but there was one point when i was
getting like 50 feet to the stage
that i could feel my soul putting the
brakes on but my feet were taking me
there that's a really weird feeling
my feet were walking there like i had
done it 20 000 times before which i
[ __ ] did
and it was like i was just fi i remember
looking down and just following my feet
is that the weirdest thing i could ever
say to you guys like i was
it just took me there it just took me to
the front of the stage
i walked out people were in shock they
thought tom [ __ ]
went to sleep and woke up like [ __ ]
rip ram winkle whatever his name
the dude who fell asleep for 20 years
with a beard people were looking like
that's not [ __ ] time that's
[ __ ] uncle joey
and i tell you i had a little fear to me
which was natural you got to have a
little fear
i [ __ ] up my lines i said [ __ ]
three times
but those five minutes
were [ __ ] mind-boggling guys
when i went up there and they just went
wow
listen there's a big difference between
200 people
and a couple thousand people
i'ma tell you something i've been doing
this for 30 [ __ ] years i've spoken
about it before out of place because
i really didn't know
but after friday that was the first
i feel people's energy you ever feel
somebody's energy when you go in a room
or
they come in the room and they [ __ ] up
the energy of the room or something
this was the first time i felt that
energy from the stage
like i just felt
there was a point you ever see that uh
remember years ago is it tape or is it
memorex
and the guy would sit in front of the
speaker and his [ __ ] hair would blow
and [ __ ] that's what i felt like up on
stage i felt like
my eyes were pinned like the energy from
you [ __ ]
made my eyebrows just go up and stick
you it was the weirdest [ __ ] feeling
it was just stuck
i felt my adrenaline going i could feel
my eyeballs turning red
i thought it was the viagra i had viagra
three nights earlier whenever you
whenever i eat viagra my eyes get all
[ __ ] red and [ __ ] i look like one of
those
so
i could feel the heat in my head i
brought up jeff tate who was very funny
one of tom's openers
and i had to immediately sit down guys
it felt like a heart attack
meets an erection
meets a stroke meets a finger in the ass
i i was i really was i was i was blown
the [ __ ] away guys even though i've been
in this for 30 years
when i walked off that stage there was
one option and that was just to sit down
i couldn't walk anymore my mind wouldn't
let me
it was like uh 19 months of something
just came out of me i was wiped out
i sat down you know i said thank you i
talked to jimmy i started drinking water
and i just focused on tom
and it was the weirdest thing because
while i was watching tom i could hear
his material but my mind was racing
if you've ever been on stage
my mind was [ __ ] racing while i was
watching tom and i was picking up key
words as the set went on longer
i could focus i could hear tom and tom
was [ __ ] hilarious
the way he connected that set it was
[ __ ] brilliant he
he's really at the top of his game i'm
not saying this
just because he's my brother but he
really is at the top of his game
and uh
i was just blown the [ __ ] away you know
i didn't know what to do
after about 25 minutes
my wife texted me and asked me how it
went
and i said i actually went up on stage
and brought tom and you know my wife
started crying at dinner
she was with her friends at dinner
and she started crying
and i asked her why
and she said because she was happy
my voice sounded different
and she said that
she was happy
that i was out of the house
you know i'm a lucky dude guys i got a
wife that's very
understanding
i got a wife that supports me you know
she tells me [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] like
sometimes but
after a few hours i think about what her
words are and i understand maybe
sometimes i ingest them a little
different
but she was [ __ ] ecstatic
you know she was really happy and i
could tell
like the moms she was with the next day
i saw him
and they were like hey man your wife was
really [ __ ] happy so
you know when i got home that night we
spoke a little bit about uh how i felt
what did i think
and you know i don't know
i still don't know i didn't miss it me
going on stage you know one of the guys
on patreon said he goes i knew you were
going to get on stage i got heard in
your voice i go i didn't know i was
going to get on stage
i didn't know i was going to get on
stage i thought i was just going to sit
on the side and watch tom
but him bringing me up there was just
listen i slept like a baby that night
i got home
i think i didn't even [ __ ] take my
[ __ ] uh zequil
or my benadryl i had to go upstairs and
just go to sleep
it was it had taken everything out of me
it also let me know who i was that night
for a brief moment
and what i had done and
it kind of felt good it really did it's
like wow so
you know i'm a [ __ ] theater comic i
am what i [ __ ] am what i am when i
came back here my head was a little
[ __ ] up and i went to do a couple
clubs
and they're great clubs or whatever but
the kovic those numbers remember like i
was performing for 47 people you know
for a while the time i was doing the
shows it was only 47 people i was
performing for
so i don't know
the reason i stopped going on stage was
because it didn't feel right
i'll tell you something friday night
felt 100 right it really [ __ ] did
it felt like i belonged but you know i
came home i spoke to my wife
we spoke about what we wanted
i got to tell you guys what happened
okay
when you enthrall yourself with
something whether it's a band
you get into the welders union and all
of a sudden you're working 80 hours a
week but you're getting better at what
you're doing and you're learning a skill
and you're moving up and you start
making more money you get
really [ __ ] enthusiastic it really
shows you
you know i stopped
going to the store all those years i
started doing a podcast and all of a
sudden all this [ __ ] started happening
my stand-up hadn't caught up to the
podcast you know i remember going out a
few times and eating a bag of [ __ ] and
then i
you know found out what was going on and
i started shining as a headline and i
moved into [ __ ] theaters
[Music]
you know i
i'm the type of guy listen i don't
really realize what i've done until i do
it like years later like i don't know
what i do to me it's just another day
but i really try hard not to be
a big shot i try hard not to have a
[ __ ]
you know ego i know that that's the [ __ ]
that takes you down
quicker than [ __ ] herpes quicker than
coke you know
ego and [ __ ] being a jerk off
is not gonna
get you to the next level so
when i took that time off in 2007 from
going to the store i also
took time away from being in the big
leagues you gotta understand that
when you're at the store every night
you're in the [ __ ] big leagues
whether it's 180 people or you're in the
main room for 450. you're in the big
leagues you get elevated
the guy in front of you is a killer and
the guy behind you is the killer and the
10 people went on before you that
[ __ ] killers when you move into a
small area
like where i'm at in this metropolitan
area of new jersey
you don't run with a lot of killers
so i think that
took a little
toll on me you know i did it was a lot
of things to move but my point is that
here's the deal guys when you're young
whatever you dive into is [ __ ] great
you know whether it's plumbing
whatever the [ __ ] you dive into and when
you start putting your hours in 80 hours
a week
you start [ __ ] staying away from your
friends not because you hate them or you
don't want them because you're focused
they're just gonna throw and then after
a while like man we haven't seen you in
a long time come out you know it's been
three months and then they beat you up
again but once you go out with them
you're like [ __ ] that sucked i gotta get
back to what i was doing whether it's
playing the ukulele or [ __ ] playing
the guitar whatever the [ __ ] you're like
that that was okay but i'll keep that to
a [ __ ] minimum they got to realize
i'm on a [ __ ] mission okay
and you make your life that thing for me
from the uncle joey
i made my life comedy i didn't give a
[ __ ] about anything else
you know i see people and they always
say to me oh i'm having a problem doing
this i didn't uh
i can't get ahead in life oh how much
time are you putting [ __ ] into this
let's see is this what you
[ __ ] eat chew and sleep
or is this a hobbyist
when i go to new jersey
i am uh
when i go to jiu jitsu
i'm not a fighter
i'm not a [ __ ] young man
so i'm a hobbyist
that's what i can it's just a hobby i do
it's a part of my social mental
physical development to stay in shape
you know uh reefer causes dementia i
don't want to start [ __ ]
you know talking about ghosts and [ __ ] i
don't know i don't know so when you get
older it's good to box a little bit like
after you're 50 it's good to just hit
the mids have somebody throw targets at
you and
remember moves one two three four five
you know when i go to jiu jitsu i do the
moves i count
i count the first leg goes up up your
back is straight the second leg goes up
you grab the leg that's the easiest
thing for me if not i'm a [ __ ] idiot
with it but i'm a hobbyist
when i got into comedy
i didn't have anything else it was
comedy cocaine
okay the two c's
and [ __ ] ccp that's all i [ __ ] knew
i had a bench in my living room i did
you know bench presses at night and bent
over rows and [ __ ]
but that was just uh you know
but i put my time into this and the sad
thing is it became my life
and that's exactly what i wanted
i wanted to dive into something and
again you know you all you guys watching
listen
whatever you love it depends how much
you could dive into it but then things
change the battlefield changes
uh
you know i got a girlfriend
she wanted me at home a little more
i got a i gotta and then i got married
and she wanted me
a little more you know to be around
and that was after 2009
and then i actually gave comedy up the
podcast came in
and i dove back into it
you guys know i was doing a podcast a
day with everybody whether it was red
band with uh podcats podcats podcats
or i was always doing something rogue
and eddie bravo you know and we
perfected the [ __ ] podcast we learned
how to communicate on it you guys
watched the growth i didn't invent the
[ __ ] podcast
somebody brought it up and we started
doing it from [ __ ] whatever we knew
but i dove into this once i had the kid
i was still immersed in this [ __ ]
game
throughout the years as my daughter
matured
i tried to loosen my schedule a little
more i knew the direction i wanted to
and then with the [ __ ] move it made
me realize that my life was comedy
i didn't talk about anything else
i didn't care about anything else
that's how i had it treated
for me to succeed
everybody has a different thing
once i got here i realized how over i
was over playing the card
i was really working a little bit too
much
i wanted to get [ __ ] uh situated i
wanted to see which one
direction the wind was blowing i didn't
[ __ ] know what's going on here so i
didn't want to get off the plane and
just dive into it in a way i didn't
and that's why i couldn't complete the
[ __ ] uh
you know whatever i just was not ready
and that's okay when you're not ready
and i took some time
and now i'm ready so now i had to come
home that night talk to my wife
i'm gonna try to go out a few nights
this week maybe just do a
couple sets you know
um
i can't go out in the headline 45
minutes i'm not going to charge you 25
bucks
for material that's not there i can't do
that even though people will start
calling me listen
i wasn't even off the stage
and people were texting me
by the time i was sitting on the side my
agent called me what's going on i just
got a text
listen guys you know and
i can't go back to where i was
i would uh
do a residency in vegas maybe find a
room in vegas to tropicana wherever i
was treasure island
i would find myself a little home down
here whether it be red bank or ac
and i would do new york and jersey and
boston you know when time permits guys i
don't want to do a [ __ ] late show
i want to do an eight o'clock show i'd
open it me it come on at eight in fact
let's start at 7 45.
get the opener me
and we're out of here by nine that's it
that's how i want to do it from now on
i really don't want to do a lot of clubs
i want to do small theaters in this area
you know i i just listen i worked so
hard
to get into a theater
there's a big [ __ ] gap
when you go from a comedy club from
being an emcee then working yourself to
a feature then working yourself to a
headline and now you gotta learn how to
perform in the theater completely
different
and i'm very happy like like sebastian
kevin joe
there's a bunch of guys that are doing
arenas uh tom listen
going into arena for the first time you
have to change your act up you have to
learn the timing now there's more of a
dip
from your words to them
to bounce back to you
you might not think you're doing well
and you're [ __ ] doing fantastic
there's 18 15 000 people in there
they're up in the [ __ ] nosebleeds
what do you think you can hear them
[ __ ] laugh
so this is another thing you have to
learn oh my god guys there's no you know
what do you think g r went from doing
you know the whiskey right and all of a
sudden they're on the road opening then
they [ __ ] started headlining then
they were doing massive [ __ ] tours
i still remember g r coming to jersey
and seeing the pictures in fact they
shot paradise city video from giants
[ __ ] stadium if you look at it look
at all those [ __ ] people there what
do you think that they didn't adjust
their material in just their music or
the levels of the music as you move up
you're learning it's a learning [ __ ]
thing so i put close to
five years of learning how to perform in
the theater and making it work i don't
want to just get rid of it now
so my plan is maybe i'll [ __ ] do a
couple small rooms no headlining spots
no weekends i got too much going on the
[ __ ] weekends uncle joey's gonna
become the comic you love to see on
wednesday and thursday night wednesday's
a good night get out of the house [ __ ]
suck it's hump day it's time to have
some [ __ ] drinks smoke a few [ __ ]
numbers and get the party started jack
i think in the summer i gotta lay low
friend of mine offered me a little tour
i got to see where i stand if he wants
me to do 45 minutes or 20 minutes
if he wants me to do 45 again i can't do
it i have to be honest with myself
i want to put together a tremendous set
and then get the [ __ ] out of this the
pace i have no idea
do i want to go around the world in 80
days in a [ __ ] balloon [ __ ] no
this will be nice and light so uncle
joey doesn't [ __ ] and and i still want
to focus on my jujitsu i still want to
focus on the book that's coming out i
know rewrites are coming so before i get
involved i want to see what's coming
with the book i want the book
to be in [ __ ] bed and right now we're
looking at
november of 2023 hopefully after they
read it
and they see the damage that we could do
we could release it this [ __ ]
november have some book parties you know
the whole [ __ ] thing book and reefer
parties the whole [ __ ] thing you know
the laughing gas people are really
helped happy i love them to death
because they knew that there was a a
kink there was something missing and
everything that i'm doing right now
okay guys there's something missing
the podcast was starting to build was
starting to grow i'm getting a little
smoother
learning how to do an hour podcast by
myself and then having a guest on
[ __ ] wednesday we're trying to
[ __ ] figure out how we're going to
incorporate i mean mike did a great job
last week with three [ __ ] people in
the room i mean it was as good as a
podcast as it could be
and it worked so uh
i'm gonna start getting a couple guests
and grow there but the main thing was to
[ __ ] stand up it just took
i wanted to fall in love with it and i'm
not even in love with it right now
i want to see this week how
aggressive i am and
one night just going because i did go
out thursday night last week too guys i
had a nice little time
thursday night i actually went to watch
comedy
i had a place called stacks a breakfast
joint [ __ ] tremendous
if you go in there get the iron man dish
it's filet mignon two eggs peppers
onions
potatoes [ __ ] wheat toast delicious
delicious but they gotta i think they're
only open for brunch nice people
they uh have comedy night there and they
invited me a few times but it was always
like the day of
so thursday i went up there but there
was no parking you know because they're
next to [ __ ] cousins great restaurant
and that place is [ __ ] always
jam-packed great food i haven't been
there i got a hyoma visit a little mid
podcast ad listen you may not realize
but headaches teeth grinding and even
digestive issues can be indicators of
stress other stress indicators of doom
scrolling sleeping too little or too
much under-reading or ovary put simply
stress shows up in all kinds of ways in
this world that's telling you to do more
and grind all the time
this is your reminder to take care of
yourself do less and maybe a little
therapy to talk to somebody to break
things up tell the folks listen to me
as far as i'm concerned better help got
me out of my [ __ ] slump better help
online therapy is tremendous it's
customized online therapy it offers you
video chat and even live
chat sessions with your therapist if you
don't want to be on camera you don't
have to it's much more affordable than
in person therapy you do it right from
the privacy in your own house give it a
try and see if online therapy can help
lower your stress the joint is sponsored
by better help and our listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
slash diaz listen if it helped me it can
help you too we all put our pants on one
leg at a time
referred to dana that's who helped me
and took me out of my anxiety issues
but first go to betterhelp.com
slash diaz and get 10 off
online therapy inline therapy whatever
you want to call it online therapy the
best
slash
bettahelp.com
last time i went there it was probably
like nine [ __ ] months ago
but anyway i got there and they were uh
it was just packed i couldn't find the
parking spot
i went down the road to the osteria and
i did something i haven't done in years
i had a gin and tonic and watched the
[ __ ] brooklyn uh
game against the i think it was the
milwaukee bucks
i watched one called i go i gotta get
out of here it's getting creepy in here
and then i go where am i going what the
[ __ ] am i doing with my life
what do i want to run home for to sit in
my [ __ ] chair
and i said let me watch till halftime
also some ladies started talking to me a
husband
i'm like [ __ ] i watched the third
quarter next thing you know the game was
over
[ __ ] milwaukee came back and beat
brooklyn we couldn't [ __ ] believe it
i almost had a heart attack [ __ ]
and i was out the whole game
i stayed out the whole game guys
drove home got a little [ __ ] car
second on the way home but no big deal
came home [ __ ] hung out with the wife
talked to her a little bit my next
venture is a strip club
i'm gonna go to a strip club to see
what's going on you see how i'm
attacking this i'm attacking this
strategy little by little you know what
i'm saying there's a couple strip clubs
not really there's one i want to go to
that one of my dear friends owned i'm
going to stop in there and say hello to
him
look at some young [ __ ] punani you
know what i'm saying and uh run the [ __ ]
out of there i don't like lap dances
they creep me the [ __ ] out your jeans
smell like [ __ ] rotten ass and [ __ ]
when you go home
you know i can't deal with that [ __ ]
but the other thing that happened this
weekend that was really [ __ ] cool
i you know
guys i'm getting used to all this [ __ ] i
wasn't a family i i don't know about
this you know when i was a kid
[Music]
there was an understanding in my house
you come and [ __ ] go i mean we hung
out every once in a while
but not the way i'm doing it now like i
i
guys you gotta understand i'm new to
this
i'm a [ __ ] prisoner of death i'm uh
i'm a low-life scumbag and my family and
so this whole family life has been
just you know like uh it's all new to me
i'm enjoying it i'm basking in it i
[ __ ] love it i love my wife more than
ever
i love my daughter more than ever but
i'm
like [ __ ] we're going to a different
level here it's like when you get a cat
when you get a cat you don't know what
to expect
the first year it's kind of [ __ ]
shitty it's okay you know you love him
you throw papers up in the air he
scratches them you got your little
feather with the stick
you know you smoke a joint i'll [ __ ] i
used to play with that stick for hours
that's the kind of loser i am i could
play for [ __ ] hours on that stick
and then after a year you're like wow
something's happening here we're
building a bond and the longer that
cat's around or that dog's around
it gets better and better and better and
you just keep doing what you're doing
and you fall in love with the pet the
pet falls in love with you whatever
it's the same thing with
these kids you know
i don't know i think people raise kids
it's tough it's tough to be a [ __ ]
parent today you know
mike and i were talking about his wife
is working nights now you know he
thought he was gonna have the [ __ ]
swing a lifetime while his wife was
working nights and
it's rough and you have to put the
sacrifice in him and what are you gonna
do what's mike gonna do leave some
[ __ ] stranger with his kids overnight
so
it's tough being a [ __ ] parent but at
the same time it's very rewarding
it's very rewarding you know and uh
i never wanted kids i know a lot of
years like [ __ ] kids i get it
i get it but someday you're going to
meet a girl you're going to knock her up
and now you got a kid and then you're
going to go [ __ ]
i'm thinking about uncle joey now for
what he said because i was one of those
[ __ ] i don't want a kid i don't
want to be married
but uh
saturday night my daughter had a
sleepover but my wife didn't want to do
the sleepover because [ __ ]
she had a doubleheader on sunday
[ __ ] season just started on saturday
and also they want to have a
doubleheader i was praying for rain you
know me i got that i did that 23andme i
got that indian blood i'm out there
jumping up and down for rain saturday
night and sure enough it rained sunday
they canceled the games i got to go to
the gym
do the podcast go to jiu jitsu it was a
great [ __ ] day the lord's day but
saturday night my wife didn't want to
[ __ ] uh let her sleep over
so i was supposed to go see my man rudy
sarzo
and my heart goes out to him
i was supposed to go to vineland with
the florentine brothers
they were supposed to have a sleepover
and one of the dads was supposed to
watch him
there was an emergency at [ __ ] work
the dad could watch him this is a
tremendous story all of a sudden all the
parents like well you could watch them
till the mom gets there and i'm like so
now i'm [ __ ] stuck i didn't care i
had a good time i went
and got some food for them they got some
chick-fil-a it was great
and then when it was time to leave you
know i stayed watch the end of the north
carolina game [ __ ] tremendous
kansas and north carolina tonight
[ __ ] tonight's a good night for
draftkings too
sign up tonight you got the [ __ ] five
dollars when you're 200 cotton free bets
and then you roll right into [ __ ]
saturday's ufc with peter yan and
[ __ ] ah
what do you think you're dealing with
joey [ __ ] bananas you go you guys
know i'm teaching you the scam of life
here they give you 200 free credits it's
either one or the other on monday night
it's either kansas another [ __ ]
carolina and when you win or lose
they'll give you the 200 credits and you
roll it into the weekend you got [ __ ]
uh new jersey's mickey goal on the card
this week you got [ __ ] volonoski you
got that crazy
chimian fighting gilbert burns guys
who takes care you're like me you got to
set up the [ __ ] week anyway
i [ __ ] go over there and it's about 9
30. north carolina [ __ ] wins
ankle burst we got to go home
take a shower as soon as i get in the
car
she's upset as [ __ ] you know she's
crying i gotta talk her off the [ __ ]
thing
you know my wife is strict guys and you
have to play a little strict i mean my
wife knew it was going to be a long
weekend so she's like i don't want to
sleep now because then she won't sleep
and she's got a double head and she'll
fall asleep out in the field
so i bring her home we talk a little bit
we're talking in the car
i'm like oh listen you got no reason to
be upset you're [ __ ] nine there's
gonna be 200 more [ __ ] sleepovers for
you to sleep at
we'll go home tonight i'll pull out some
[ __ ] ice cream i didn't have dick
here so i i couldn't it was too late to
go to carvel
she was upset you know and uh
i talked her off the ledge and i go
listen what we could do is let's go home
get some snacks go downstairs
we'll watch sopranos and uh you can have
your own [ __ ]
little sleep away downstairs you know
she sets up the [ __ ] blanket with her
little teddy bears she comes down
so she was still upset
when i was putting on pajamas i could
hear it in the shower where she was a
little upset so
i knocked on the door and we talked to
the [ __ ] door and i go listen i'll be
downstairs waiting for you let's talk
she came down
i explained you know about her situation
and all of a sudden
[ __ ] out of the blue
bruce lee was on last night
god damn and it's my favorite
listen bruce lee put out four movies you
know
i like the original fist of fury
i like
what i watched last night it was build
this fist of fury but it's really the
chinese connection they called it the
chinese connection and landed here in
1970
and uh
that's my i'll enter the dragon is great
[ __ ]
the one with kareem abdul-jabbar ah
that's a [ __ ] boring movie
but chinese connection there was
something about that movie that always
blew me the [ __ ] away
as i got older i saw how good bruce
lee's acting was in that movie it was
[ __ ] raw
you know he had steve mcqueen in his ear
he was watching what clint clinicia was
doing over there in italy
and bruce had a [ __ ] plan to do the
same thing in [ __ ] china out of hong
kong make those movies build his name
come back to america and spank these
[ __ ] which was his initial
mission until he went to some broads
house and she gave him a [ __ ] roofie
and he died of a [ __ ] headache or
that's what they told us with chinese
people you never know you could touch
them in the neck and they got a headache
somebody said they hit him with the
[ __ ] touch of death the day before
anyway
when all that [ __ ] happened i was
[ __ ] heartbroken but nevertheless
this is my all-time favorite bruce lee
movie
so when she came downstairs like
immersed check this out and she was a
little upset her eyes were still red i
put bruce lee and she just [ __ ] froze
and if you know anything about that
movie he just starts killing
[ __ ] one at a time
you know there's kung fu scenes
where he [ __ ] up a whole karate school
but with that movie he took out one at a
time
he started with the [ __ ] guy who
poisoned his teacher and his little
[ __ ]
kitchen assistant that's when he broke
his inside just a raw [ __ ] scene
why'd you kill my teacher why why why
why the guy just [ __ ] dies he punches
him like 20 times in the stomach
tremendous then he goes after feng shui
and then he [ __ ]
goes after the interpreter for the
school and he hangs him on a [ __ ]
tree tremendous i mean that movie he
goes off
uh the plot is he [ __ ] went away when
he comes back he finds his teacher dead
and he [ __ ] loses it and then at the
[ __ ] wake the japanese school came
over talking that karate [ __ ] with
sandals on and they insulted him and
they said he was [ __ ] yellow and [ __ ]
oh my god and the next day bruce lee
shows up at the school they had a
picture that says sick man of asia on it
referring to his [ __ ] master this
[ __ ] walks into school and he
goes i come to bring this back but you
gotta take it from me that's how i'm dog
he doesn't play in that movie he [ __ ]
smashes them he smashes the picture he
makes them eat the paper
then they [ __ ] i mean he just he walks
to a zoo
and some guy tells him if you want to
walk in the park you got to crawl on the
floor like a chinese oh my god he just
blew away three more japanese people
fresh from the sushi restaurant and then
there was a [ __ ] hunt for him and
then he started doing [ __ ] disguises
he started disguising like a little old
man and [ __ ] and [ __ ] these old
newspapers he disguised himself as a
phone man
this mother he's designed himself as a
[ __ ] nick saw or not yik saw what's
that a hicks rickshaw uh yik saw
rickshaw a [ __ ] driver tremendous
so [ __ ] i mean this is my all-time
favorite movie and then at the end he
turns himself in to the ching woo school
and he [ __ ]
as he's walking outside he said that
they double-crossed them
and all of them got guns and [ __ ] and
instead of standing like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he runs out into the [ __ ] thing and
they shoot him he hear bullets you don't
really know if bruce lee lives or dies
that's the beauty of it but years after
that that was just a singular story it
wasn't connected to the other [ __ ]
movies guys i saw that movie
that movie was my baby you know how i do
the album of the week on patreon
and these are my babies that movie's my
[ __ ] baby
it was uh
i don't know maybe 1969
i was going to sacred heart school for
boys i was in the [ __ ] fourth grade
we were watching happy days happy days
it just came on the [ __ ] air
that's how old i am and
a commercial came on a trailer
for that [ __ ] movie
and oh my lord when he's at the karate
school beating the [ __ ] up
listen there were 20 young 4
4th graders now when you're in the
fourth grade
and you see somebody beating the [ __ ]
out of somebody you're jumping up and
down like a [ __ ] [ __ ] right you're
just
you're just floundering get them buy
them whatever the [ __ ] it is right so
that [ __ ] trailer came on guys you
could hear a pin drop in that
[ __ ] room i will never ever
ever forget that night as long as i
[ __ ] live you could have heard a pin
drop in that [ __ ]
and i'll never forget my stepdad one
picking me up on friday and going what
do you want to do this weekend i said
listen i don't know about the weekend
i know what we're doing tonight we're
going to the [ __ ] to see the chinese
connection i don't give a [ __ ] where
it's playing and as we were headed home
clifton on route 3 [ __ ] north there
used to be a driving theater there
and what do you think they were playing
the [ __ ] chinese connection now
that's why i saw my first [ __ ]
gangster movie i saw five fingers of
that that's the first
anybody that knows [ __ ] kung fu
movies that's one of the first movies
that hit the [ __ ]
the united states oh tremendous his hand
turns pink and [ __ ]
tremendous that was all about the iron
palm technique that's why i saw that
movie
when i saw the chinese connection i lost
my [ __ ] mind and not to make things
worse it was also playing at the union
city cinema my home base at the time up
in union city i saw all my movies in
there
i still remember walking home from there
and after a karate movie and just
looking for a [ __ ] fight with
somebody
and then by the time we got the 32nd
street there was ponte corvo deli
so we we kicked the [ __ ] out of all the
boxes me and my little hoodlums pinot
[ __ ] mike
we'd [ __ ] up these [ __ ] boxes there'd
be boxes all over bergeron avenue and
then we go to my mother's bar and i'd
walk in there with a karate stance and
[ __ ] and then i lost my i would tell
everybody a plot of the story
you know it it made me sad but i said
sit down let's watch it
and we were [ __ ] going off her and i
and at the end i was watching it through
the corner of my eye i could see her
through through my tears at the end when
bruce lee runs out and [ __ ] and they
shoot and he yells i could tell her eyes
uh teared up i i was just [ __ ] crying
i was just thinking about
everything that movie makes me think
about going back to my mom's bar
trying to [ __ ] explain the chinese
affection to my mom and my mom going
what the [ __ ] are you talking about have
a drink shut the [ __ ] up
you just walked in here with 22
sentences in a row
it just gave me a good feeling and to
watch it
with my [ __ ] daughter
come on man and for her to enjoy it
never mind watch it with your daughter
because they could always go yeah i
don't like this and all of a sudden your
feelings get hurt but i even ask like
you wanna put the sopranos on she's like
no i like this movie dad i saw this
before so i was my dick got hard i had a
tear in my eye i mean guys there's
nothing more special
than you watching like a [ __ ] killer
movie with your daughter yeah your son
you're expected he's supposed to watch
those things unless he [ __ ] you know
wants to grow up to sniff flowers and
[ __ ]
they got to watch those things right
here but your daughter you know girls oh
they want to hear barbie and [ __ ]
pink [ __ ] and she's over there cheering
for bruce lee she's like why are they
fighting them why are they saying all
this [ __ ] about chinese people because
they're japanese people she's like that
mean daddy yeah they [ __ ] mean but
watch bruce smack the [ __ ] living
[ __ ] out of them so it was just
it was just uh
it was really a great feeling to
to just i don't know guys this might
sound stupid to you
you guys might think i'm a [ __ ]
weakling but it was just it's like full
circle
you know now she gets to experience
bruce lee
and she gets the [ __ ] piece of her
dad i don't know what i'm going to go
i'm [ __ ] i'm getting old here but
every day that i
could uh put some influence in the car
or
just give her the same things that
brought me joy as a kid just for her to
know
you know when she goes to a party and
somebody's like yeah [ __ ] you know
this guy's the baddest martial artist my
daughter will say [ __ ] you it's bruce
[ __ ] lee my dad saw him and then
she'll describe the movie so
that little bond that you get with your
children sometimes uh
for some people it's nothing for me
since i've never had it before
it's the [ __ ] world man it's the
[ __ ] world
you know she we watched bruce lee and
then we put the [ __ ] sopranos on and
we were talking [ __ ] her and i about the
surprise she asked me stupid questions
and
then i said listen we could stay up we
could watch the [ __ ] honeymooners
and she goes really
and all of a sudden i could see her
little face
she had a long day baseball parades
games running around milkshakes
chick-fil-a she was beat i go listen why
don't you close your eyes for 10 minutes
and i'll wake you up when the honeymoon
was come on it was about 11 20. and she
goes really i go yeah i do this trick
though all the time
the next thing you know
she was out cold i put the blankie up on
her i finished watching the [ __ ]
sopranos
i made sure the doors were locked i gave
her a kiss
and for in her world all she wants to do
is stay downstairs
to make herself feel like she's 13 you
know what i'm saying
if that's what it takes [ __ ] it it could
be worse she might want to [ __ ] put
makeup on
and [ __ ] drink cocktails no she just
wants to stay on here
watch an adult movie with her dad and
just [ __ ] be a little girl that's it
who's better than uncle joey you
understand me so now
like i said to you guys ever since i got
back here
i was just working on getting my life
back
that's all i was doing
trying to get my life back trying to get
it settled
now when i get into comedy it's not
a [ __ ] career anymore it's a balance
it's a balance between me and my
daughter my family jujitsu [ __ ]
getting healthy working on my knee it's
just you know it's just a [ __ ]
balance for me and sometimes that's what
you need in your life if your life is
little you need a little [ __ ] balance
guys come on you know me you think i i i
go around reading about life balances i
got better things to do you know
anything i but you could feel it
you could feel it that something's not
you got to be doing something else the
last 19 months i sat in this house
you know i went out a couple nights but
i sat in this house majority just to
find out you know who the [ __ ] i was at
this age what i could do
what i couldn't do anymore and what i
don't want to do anymore you don't think
i enjoy going out and making people
laugh and talking to people from time to
time that's what i'm all about anywhere
i go i [ __ ] next thing you know i
start [ __ ] with people i like when
they don't start with the [ __ ] uh
i like when people don't know who the
[ __ ] i am and we just talk
and then at the end of the conversation
they'll go why do you look familiar to
me and then as i'm leaving i'm [ __ ]
dropping on them you ever see the
longest yard is that you some lady at
osteria told me down there she goes you
looked a little better when you were
[ __ ] chunkier women like
guys with meat on their bones i'm like
you old [ __ ] hag you
you all dirty hag you i can't i i'm not
into but listen i like [ __ ] with
people it's it's the reason why i joined
jiu jitsu was to get my social life
going as dumb as that sounds yeah it's
about the physical and the mental but
when you're in there talking with people
and touching them and [ __ ] that's as
that's as life as can get touch is the
simplest thing
you could do with people it excites you
it motivates you it drills your skin
the human touch when you shake
somebody's hand when you give somebody a
hug
you know and imagine wrestling with
somebody
you're at your most vulnerable [ __ ]
part so i i consider that like
today when i went sunday when i went
there was a kid in there that i met at
class
young guy we both joined with no stripes
now we both have two stripes
great [ __ ] kid you know i don't know
how old he is when he squeezed me to yes
there's a listen when you squeeze me to
throw me down when you throw your dad
down like that he goes no i go then why
would you draw uncle joey down like that
god sucker and they all giggle you know
it's just social stuff
so now i'm gonna take it up a [ __ ]
notch start doing some [ __ ] guest
sets at places
unannounced you know just try to have a
good time i'm not looking to shoot a
special
i'm not looking to be on comedy central
i'm not looking for anything i'm just
looking to have [ __ ] fun
this is no drama and no stress possible
if i go up if i charge 20 bucks and if i
go up and bomb i bomb for the shirt 20
you've dropped 20 on worse when i charge
you 30 i won't be [ __ ] bombing
you follow him saying to you so i'm
going to build up a little bit take my
time
and maybe in the winter do a jersey new
york tour i don't [ __ ] know i don't
know what life is going to bring and
right now at this point in my life i'm
just trying to have a good time that's
it
i have
all my heart thing is over prison she's
dead i'm not going to see my all that
[ __ ] behind me now it's time to [ __ ]
relax and have a great time with you
[ __ ] smoke some weed sell some
weed laughing gas is about to [ __ ] go
big i will keep you [ __ ] posted
on the details
a little
little laughing gas paper pen for your
little live resin pen you all get all
this [ __ ] at the ice cream shop
i might go uh thursday night to the 58th
anniversary of the comedy store i looked
at plane tickets last night ouch
[ __ ]
those [ __ ] listen first they
were passing the cost of gas to you with
the luggage remember and they never turn
that back they're still taking half a
yard from us or a hundred bucks of
luggage these [ __ ] don't think
uncle joey is paying attention but i'm
paying attention and now they raise
their pla their plane prices again to
reflect the coaster the cost of [ __ ]
gas guys give it a [ __ ] breather i
saw what happy [ __ ] carriers
made last year you made a lot of money
no matter what the [ __ ] price the gas
was or whatever give us a [ __ ]
breathe it's the summertime these
[ __ ] are going nuts with their
prices food everything has gone up i
mean listen nothing to worry about just
keep working hard
if you can steal a steak from time to
time put it under your jacket it worked
for me for years if you don't have no
felonies or misdemeanors you could cry
yourself out of it i don't know what to
tell you it's getting harder out there
so it's time to pay more attention to
what the [ __ ] going on
it's a beautiful day to be alive it's
monday the 4th of april
and that's it for uncle joey's joint
today man i just wanted to
pop up here on a [ __ ] monday
say hello and get you ready for a new
month because it's a whole new set of
rules you got a sling new [ __ ] dick
and you got to have new [ __ ] ideas
wednesday we got a tremendous zoom guest
and we'll go a little longer we'll [ __ ]
around with you people but uh
as far as today we're done
i love you [ __ ] with all my heart
have a great day stay black and i'll see
you [ __ ] wednesday the sixth
tip top [ __ ] magoo stay black
all right you bad [ __ ] thank
you for listening we did a little solo
today
talked about the chinese connection
talked about me getting on stage was a
great time but now it's time to make
some [ __ ] getus from the heart of new
jersey the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen it starts tonight
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now
because tonight we got a [ __ ] same
game paul a with kansas and north
carolina
in the national championship once you
get up on 200 credits
then this weekend we got action with ufc
273
the official sports betting partner ufc
new customers bet 5 hours on any fighter
and get 100 in free bets win lose
guaranteed now if there's no gambling in
your state you could play for a share
millions in prizes with the draftkings
daily fantasy mma contest draft your
lineup of fighters while staying under
the salary cap and rack up points for
strikes
takedowns and more draftkings are safe
secure and reliable and best of all you
can withdraw deposit and withdraw cash
whenever you want download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
joey and throw five dollars on any ufc
273 fight and get 1000 free bets no
matter what were you crazy or what
that's code joey this saturday at
draftking sports book or tonight for the
ncaa championship
21 over restrictions applied i love you
[ __ ] the joint is also brought
to you by
betterhelp.com
diaz listen better help online therapy
is
the best therapy you could do for
yourself from the privacy
of your own home in this world what's
going on right now
with the more you grind the more the you
know inflation everything that's going
on
maybe a reminder to take care of
yourself do a little less drink some
more water and maybe talk to somebody
that's smoothing out the humps and the
bumps in your life you could tell the
folks at home
that better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy give
it a try and see if online therapy can
help lower your stress and help mine the
joint is sponsored by better health and
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month at metahub.com
diaz that's
dot
betterhelp.com
slash diaz the joint is also brought to
you by my all-time favorite c b d lion
listen whether you got pains anxiety
stress
cbd line i'll help you go to cbd lion
and read how cbd can help you
they got the third party lab results
they'll blow your [ __ ] mind read
learn and see how cbd lion can integrate
into your life go to cbd line right now
pressing code joey and get 20 off your
first order it's that easy tip top magoo
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
betterhelp.com
and i also want to thank draftkings.com
i love you [ __ ] have a great
monday stay black and i'll see you
wednesday morning tip top my goof uncle
joey's [ __ ] circus of love
um
[Music]
you